dylan you got any like
wild predictions
around bitcoin that like may be
super far-fetched but if they came true
you're thinking about them already um i
mean i think i've probably said most of
the the crazy expectations i have on
this show before but i mean i definitely
think in this decade we're going to see
central banks whether they announce or
not just
printing money to buy bitcoin in the
same way they print money to monetize
debt um you know like or like for
instance like the swiss central bank
prince prince frank's
buys dollars buys u.s equities
prints you know just to devalue their
currency makes their their exports more
attractive and they get dollar
denominated assets like the swiss
national bank owns tesla stock they own
apple stock you know so i guess they
already kind of own in a way kind of
they have some bitcoin exposure but like
they're totally i totally believe and
this is still somewhat of like an
outlandish prediction in like mainstream
circles uh in legacy finance but yeah i
totally think that's coming um and i
definitely not priced in
at a trillion dollar asset class what
would happen if that occurred like what
happens to price how does it play i mean
for for them to even secure a meaningful
allocation price is gonna have to get
bid like crazy but when that's announced
i told what like a million dollars more
or less
uh i mean if a
you know legit like
g7 central bank or you know ecb fed
boj i don't think that's that's here yet
um but yeah i mean
hundreds of thousands of dollars high
six figures uh a million eventually and
then it's like what's the purchasing
power what's the value of a dollar or a
fiat currency at that point um because
you're i mean if never mind bitcoin like
price price your your money and energy
right that i mean that's really like
what what it all comes down to is what's
your purchasing power for a barrel of
oil right um and like something like
gold or over the long term really can
kind of maintain that but i think
bitcoin is still completely underpriced
in terms of energy and we focus on like
i talk all the time like the marginal
the marginal production costs of bitcoin
in energy terms or really anything the
marginal production cost of satoshi's is
programmatically designed to increase
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time